all right let you know right out the
gate this video was brought to you by
squarespace the all-in-one platform to
build your online presence and run your
business we're gonna talk about that a
little later but first a wizard is never
late to frodo pagans no it's all a
little late on this one doesn't matter
time's not real it's an illusion and now
we're talking about arcane so arcane is
a netflix series it's about nine
episodes long came out in blocks of
three episodes i believe takes place in
the league of legends world it's
actually a league of legends prequel
something that people told me in the
comment section of my video where i said
i was gonna talk about arcane eventually
my favorite thing about that was when
people were like dude you should really
talk about arcane one day i see you not
watching my video before you come in yes
never played league of legends so when i
was watching this anything was possible
from my perception and my perspective i
didn't know who was going to live who's
going to die it was kind of amazing in a
show like this that really has great
tension yeah from i didn't know who
powder was at all that third episode
flip happens where you're like oh oh wow
oh wow this
got a whole lot deeper all in all in
short if you want to review there's a
lot that works in arcane animation
characters world building style now
first of all the animation the
animation's impressive it's slick also
cinematography it has all the scope and
grand scale of live action but just on
the much more affordable animated style
but i couldn't imagine this world being
presented in anything but this animated
form it works when presenting the
visuals of that seemingly perfect
technologically advanced top world but
also the grit of that underworld that's
essentially run by crime bosses the
animation works well in this steampunk
world
in which their technology is based off
of arcane magic also the animation works
for the action more than a few great
shootouts and action sequences but yeah
in terms of world building world tone
and action sequences i couldn't imagine
the animation being more perfectly
suited but also the characters i really
loved
most all the characters in here the core
of the heart of the characters are these
two sisters that have been estranged
from each other so that's your hero
villain conflict right there but even
calling it a hero villain conflict just
as it left my mouth it doesn't do it
justice more nuance than that it's not
hero and villain it's
family it's a fractured family story
actually i want to make a correction i
had heard about jinx before she was just
described to me as oh the harley quinn
character of league of legends and even
that leaving my mouth doesn't do the
character justice at least as seen in
arcane we've seen crazy characters in
live action and animation we've seen
madness before this is a very humanized
version of it it's actually a very
tragic story the kind of tragedy wrapped
in madness very few storytelling ever
actually sticks the landing of this was
a straight up bullseye but it's not just
the story of vi and jinx being these
estranged sisters you have silko the
antagonist again a layered nuanced
character it's easy to see him as an
[ __ ] because he is but at a point in
the series i really felt like he cares
about jinx i mean he's twisted he's
[ __ ] up but he does care i suppose in
a world of heroes and villains who is a
hero who is a villain who is a
protagonist an antagonist it's all a
matter of perspective that's what the
show does really well you have jace
who's found a way to harness arcane
magic into technology he's been warned
like dude this little dude on the
council's like i've seen what this does
don't do that don't do that but no it's
a great and amazing thing right and sure
it is but it also affords opportunity
something like that creates variables
and those variables
create opportunity in which people step
up to fill in those opportunities good
or bad and that's what i feel like the
heart and soul of what the show is
portraying and displaying that's what i
feel it is it's more of a human nature
telling you know ambition and what that
leads to the tragedy of a few of these
characters who by all accounts would be
considered
great humans they said about oppenheimer
and i can't even imagine the weight that
was on that guy's shoulders there's
actually a great line in here that i
feel like i'm gonna
mess up so i'm paraphrasing but it's
something along the lines of in our
pursuit for greatness we failed to do
good i was like
i don't remember that one there are a
few lines like that in here really
profound
lessons that humanity can take away it's
not just oh sweet cool world and cool
characters and let's get on with the
fighting it's one of the more effective
cautionary tales about classism and
technology and how technology can feed
into the gap of classism because when
you create a new technology it's like oh
yeah that's great for some people and
when those some people get a hold of it
and control it well what does that do
for the people who don't handle that
creates a larger divide beyond the
madness and the gunfights i felt arcane
was a very effective telling of human
nature and how anytime we get a
technology that's effective and can help
humanity our next order of business is
in fact to weaponize it black powder
nuclear energy social media and it's not
like these cautionary lessons of
classism and technology have never been
seen in entertainment ever i mean they
have many times countless times i mean
that's seen in the first 15 minutes 2001
a space odyssey the primate gets the
femur he's like sweet i have a hammer i
have a tool this can help also let's use
it to bludgeon the opposition even
jurassic park and on a finer point the
meme itself these and many more lessons
are all an arcane i just felt like
arcane did it in a more layered and
nuanced way than you usually see here in
2021 i felt like arcane did a great job
at having an interesting world
entertaining animation compelling and
layered characters with intricate
relationships among each other an
interesting world that felt alive and
lived in the politics the policy the
science all of it it felt like a world
that does in fact exist and operate that
was effectively nuanced with a
cautionary tale that's applicable to now
has been applicable since the beginning
of time and will continue to be a
relevant cautionary tale until the heat
death of the universe or at least the
death of earth by death of earth i mean
death of humanity i hope the cockroaches
that survive i hope they take those
lessons to heart but in the end if
you're not looking for any of these
lessons any of these cautionary lessons
about humanity and human nature
technology and the divide arcane is just
damn [ __ ] good entertaining
entertainment and i firmly believe one
of the things that makes arcane stand
out among video game to movie or video
game to series adaptations is that
arcane doesn't rely on the viewers
pre-existing knowledge of the world and
the characters to basically carry the
series it treats this world as though
it's the viewer's introduction to the
characters and the world so it's the
writing of the world the writing of the
characters in the series that hooks you
the interesting things about the
characters and the world is what you see
in the series not what you played in the
game smart thing to do
amazed that more adaptations don't think
like that arcane crushed it this is
actually what i'd like to see in terms
of a legacy of cane adaptation a show
that's done in the arcane style
come on legacy of kane's not dead
right and as i mentioned earlier this
video is brought to you by squarespace
truly the all-in-one platform to build
your online presence and run your
business squarespace sells over 200 top
level domains so you can find the
perfect name for your website buying a
domain from squarespace is simple no
hidden fees no price hikes you can
present videos from youtube vimeo and
animoto on your squarespace site and as
always i say it every time i love the
fact that every design automatically
comes with a unique mobile experience
that matches the overall style of your
website a killer perk in an increasingly
mobile world so go to squarespace.com
for your free trial and when you're
ready to launch your empire click the
link below go to squarespace.com
jeremyjones get yourself 10 off your
first purchase of website or domain
using promo code john's and thank you
once again to squarespace for sponsoring
this video i do appreciate it all right
so arcane the league of legends series
on netflix have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you